RECORDINGS BEING MADE OF TODAY'S
PROCEEDINGS ACT ACCORDINGLY
POSSIBLY TELL US.
SECRETARY PLEASE HOLD ROLE.
COOLEY CUNNINGHAM THEIR.
ALLEN BOROUGH. CORREO HERE
TORONTO HERE. FRIEDMAN.
GRAYSON.
PRESIDENT.
HOLLIS PRESENT. WALDRON HERE
LEVINE CARE WE HAVE A. WE HAVE A
QUORUM WE ALSO OF THE CONSENT
AGENDA AS OUR MOTION ON WHO.
WHO BY THE SPECIALIST SECOND
PREMISE FOR REAL?
PLEASE HOLD.
I THINK. MY.
I ALLEN BROUGH CARILLO AYE
CORREO AYE CERVANTES AYE
CERVANTES AYE FRIEDMAN GRAYSON
KNOWS AREA. AYE NAZARIAN AYE
SOLACE AYE SOLACE AYE WALDRON
AYE WALDRON AYE LEVINE AYE AYE
LEVINE I'D MUCH.
THE MOTION IS PASSED RULES
COMMITTEES ADJOURN.
YEAH